.
LAURA INGRAHAM IS NEXT.
SEE YOU BACK HERE TOMORROW
NIGHT.
>> Laura: I AM LAURA INGRAHAM
AND THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON.
THE CDC SAYS THE COVID VACCINE
DOESN'T ACTUALLY STOP THE SPREAD
OF THE VIRUS.
OKAY.
SO WHY ARE WE ABANDONING
UNVACCINATED TEACHERS.
WE TALKED WITH TEACHER TAKING
HER CASE TO COURT.
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
THAT'S WHAT THE NATIONAL SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION WANTS TO LABEL
PARENTS WHO STAND UP FOR THEIR
KIDS.
BIDEN INSULTS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND THEY ARE TALKING
BACK.
RAYMOND ARROYO HAS IT IN "SEEN
AND UNSEEN."
FIRST, BIG BLUE CITIES BLOCK
AMERICA.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
YOU CAN'T SAY WE DIDN'T TRY TO
WARN THEM.
IT'S BE COMING MORE OBVIOUS BY
THE DAY THAT THESE POWER-HUNGRY
GOVERNORS AND RADICAL MAYORS ARE
ENDANGERING THEIR STATES FUTURES
AND WILL EVENTUALLY SEE THEIR
STATES LEFT BEHIND.
WE TRIED TO WARN RED AND BLUE
STATES THAT IF THEY WENT THE WAY
OF EUROPE AND KIND OF SLOW
ROLLED THEIR REOPENING, THE FREE
STATES WOULD ULTIMATELY LEAVE
THEM ALL BEHIND.
SURE ENOUGH, WE SEE IT'S ALL
COME TO PASS.
DEMOCRAT RUN STATES AND CITIES
THAT DRAG YOUR FEET ON REOPENING
AND CONTINUE TO WEIGH DOWN THEIR
BUSINESSES AND SCHOOLS WITH
ALL THESE MANDATES ARE BRINGING
DOWN THE ECONOMY FOR THE REST OF
AMERICA.
ONE BLOOMBERG COLUMNIST RECENTLY
LOOKED AT THE SEVEN METRO
REGIONS.
NEW YORK, L.A., SAN FRANCISCO,
CHICAGO, D.C., BOSTON AND
PHILLY.
WHILE ALL THOSE PLACES ACCOUNTED
FOR 25% OF JOB LOSSES AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC, THEY
ARE NOW RESPONSIBLE FOR A
STAGGERING 44.8% OF THE JOB
LOSSES.
BY THE WAY, WHEN YOU BREAK IT
OUT FURTHER, THE PICTURE LOOKS
EVEN MORE GRIM.
NATIONAL AVERAGE UNAPPOINTED
RATE IS 5.2% BUT FOR NEW YORK
AND L.A., IT'S OVER 10%.
CHICAGO IS STILL ATROCIOUS AT
8%.
WHILE MAX.
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING?
BECAUSE NOT EVERYONE HAS THE
LUXURY OF WORKING FROM HOME,
PEOPLE.
AS ONE BLOOMBERG COLUMN NOTES
MANY HIGH SKILLED SERVICE
WORKERS STARTED TO WORK
REMOTELY.
AS A RESULT, LOW SKILLED SERVICE
WORKERS IN BIG CITIES BORE MOST
OF THE RECENT PANDEMIC ECONOMIC
IMPACT.
DUH.
ANYONE WITH A LITTLE BIT OF GRAY
MATTER SHOULD'VE SEEN THIS
FREIGHT TRAIN OF AN ON A
PLUMBING COMING.
IT'S ALSO HARMFUL.
IT'S ALSO UNNECESSARY.
LAWYERS AND ACCOUNTANTS DID
GREAT.
THEY WERE ABLE TO TAKE UP
KNITTING AND BEEKEEPING.
BUT FAUCI AND THE GOVERNMENT
SMUG GLOBAL ROAD ENFORCERS, THEY
DIDN'T CONSIDER WHAT THEY WERE
DOING.
THE FACTS TELL US SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON,
THE TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN NEW
TAXING AND SPENDING THE BIDEN
AFTER EVERYTHING WE HAVE BEEN
THROUGH WANTS TO RAM THROUGH.
FIRST OF ALL, WE DON'T NEED IT.
MOST OF THE U.S. ECONOMY IS
DOING FINE.
THE BLUE CITIES NEED TO FULLY
REOPEN, BRING EVERYONE BACK TO
WORK, AND JUST AS WE HAVE BEEN
SAYING FOR MONTHS.
THERE'S PLENTY OF PENT-UP DEMAND
OUT THERE IN PLENTY OF JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE JUST
GETTING STARTED IN THE
WORKPLACE.
BUT THE BLUE STATE MAYORS, YOUR
FRIENDS LIKE LORI LIGHTFOOT,
ERIC GARCETTI, BILL de BLASIO,
THE REFUSE, THEY ADAMANTLY
REFUSED TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AND INSTEAD ARE DOING EBBING
POSSIBLE TO PREVENT LIFE FROM
RETURNING TO NORMAL.
>> HERE IS MY MESSAGE TO ALL THE
MAYORS OF AMERICA.
WITH THESE MANDATES IN PLACE.
WITH THESE INCENTIVES IN PLACE.
>> WE CANNOT MAXIMIZE THE SAFETY
OF OUR WORKPLACES WITHOUT PEOPLE
BEING FULLY VACCINATED.
THAT'S MY GOAL.
>> Laura: THE GOAL.
IMAGINE IF THESE PEOPLE OPERATED
WITH THE SAVVY OF OUR FRIENDS IN
NASHVILLE OR PHOENIX.
WHILE THE LEFT DEMANDS OF SEEING
NEW LEVELS OF SPENDING, THIS IS
HAPPENING AT THE SAME TIME.
ENERGY POLICIES THEY ARE
DICTATING OR HAVING A
DEVASTATING EFFECT ON THE SAME
WORKING PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING
HAMMERED ON THE OTHER SIDE.
THE COST OF OIL RECENTLY SPIKED
TO ITS HIGHEST PRICE SINCE 2014.
WE ARE ALREADY SEEING HEADLINES
IN JUNE THAT SAID THINGS ARE
GOING TO GET WORSE AND WORSE.
NATURAL GAS GOING TO THE ROOF.
THE BOTTOM LINE, THIS WINTER
AMERICANS CAN EXPECT BIG OR
UTILITY BILLS.
IT'S NOT JUST UTILITY BILLS.
BIDEN'S CLIMATE CRUSADE WILL
LEAD TO HIGHER PRICES ON
EVERYTHING ELSE.
NATURAL GAS IS CONSUMED IN LARGE
VOLUMES TO MAKE PLASTIC,
FERTILIZERS, CEMENT.
CLIMBING GAS PRICES ARE ADDING
TO THE COST OF PRODUCING
MANUFACTURED GOODS AT A TIME
WHEN INVESTORS ARE ON THE EDGE
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL FOR RUNAWAY
INFLATION.
THERE IT IS.
THIS ISN'T AN ACCIDENT.
IT'S DEMOCRATIC POLICY.
BIDEN'S TEAM AND ITS SUPPORTERS
ON THE HILL ACTUALLY WANT YOU TO
TRAVEL LESS, TO BUY LESS, AND
FRANKLY ENJOY LIFE LESS.
THEIR WAR ON OIL AND GAS IS AN
IMMEDIATE TAX ON EVERY AMERICAN
THAT WE ARE GOING TO PAY EVERY
DAY UNTIL THE G.O.P. RETURNS TO
POWER.
NOW ON TOP OF THAT, YEAH, THEY
WANT TO SPEND MILLIONS MORE.
BIDEN AND THE LEFT WANT TO
RADICALLY CHANGE AMERICA
FOREVER.
>> WE NEED TO EXPAND MEDICAID
AND OF COURSE WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT EXPANDING
MEDICARE.
>> THE CHILD TAX CREDIT.
>> CAN YOU VOTE FOR A BILL THAT
HAS A HYDE AMENDMENT IN AD?
>> NO.
>> WE CANNOT AFFORD TO INCREASE
CARBON OR FOSSIL FUEL EMISSIONS
AT THIS TIME.
>> Laura: WE CAN'T AFFORD YOU.
CAN YOU IMAGINE, BY THE WAY, THE
FRAUD AND CRONYISM VISIT MASSIVE
LEVEL OF SPENDING IS GOING TO
INVITE?
THE DOJ CAN'T KEEP UP WITH THE
PPP FRAUD.
THEY MOVED THE MONEY THROUGH
QUICKLY INTO PEOPLE AND
BUSINESSES IT LOOKS LIKE AS MUCH
IS 15% OF IT WAS WRONGLY
AWARDED.
ONE STUDY PUT THE LOSSES AT A
STAGGERING $76 BILLION OF PPP
FRAUD.
AT THE SAME TIME THAT ALL OF
THIS IS HAPPENING, BIDEN IS FLAT
OUT LYING TO YOU.
HE ACTUALLY CLAIMS THAT WE CAN
TAKE TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
MONEY, WASTED ON FOOLISH
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS, AND THEN
THE NET COST IS 0.
>> RAISING THE DEBT LIMIT IS
ABOUT PAYING OFF OUR OLD DEBTS.
THERE'S NOTHING TO DO WITH ANY
NEW SPENDING TO BE CONSIDERED.
THERE IS NOTHING TO DO WITH MY
PLAN FOR INFRASTRUCTURE.
OUR BUILDING BACK BETTER.
0, 0, BOTH OF WHICH I MIGHT ADD
ARE PAID FOR.
>> Laura: IT WOULD BE
LAUGHABLE IF IT WEREN'T SO
TROUBLING.
BUT REMEMBER, DESPERATE MEN DO
DESPERATE THINGS.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE HEADED FOR A
WIPEOUT IN NEXT YEAR'S
CONGRESSIONAL ELECTIONS.
THEY KNOW THIS.
THEY KNOW BIDEN IS A FAILURE AND
THEY KNOW HARRIS IS WORSE.
SO NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO BORROW
AND TAX AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE,
EVEN THOUGH OUR ONLY ECONOMIC
PROBLEMS RESULT FROM THE FOOLISH
INTRANSIGENCE OF THEIR OWN
MAYORS IN THEIR OWN GOVERNORS.
AS THEY GET CLOSER TO DEFEAT,
THEY ARE GOING TO BECOME MORE
UNSTABLE.
THEY WILL HARASS PEOPLE LIKE
MANCHIN FROM THE WATER.
>> SENATOR, THIS IS AN
INVESTMENT X NECK THIS IS NOT
GIVING OUT MONEY.
THIS IS NOT SPENDING.
THIS IS INVESTING.
>> Laura: THEY WENT AFTER
SENATOR SINEMA AND WHAT SHOULD
BE A VERY PRIVATE MOMENT.
SO MUCH FOR DIGNITY AND BE
RETURNED TO NORMAL BIDEN
PROMISED US.
THEY ARE JUST PATHETIC PEOPLE
WATCHING THEIR DREAM TO CONTROL
AMERICANS AND LOWER THEIR
STANDARDS OF LIVING SLIPPING
AWAY.
BASED SEE IT.
THEY FEEL IT.
OF COURSE BIDEN IS ON BOARD WITH
THESE LUNATICS.
THE ONES THAT ARE IN THE WATER
AND THE ONES THAT ARE IN THE
BATHROOM.
COME ON.
THAT WAS AGES AGO.
THIS WAS JOE TODAY.
THE BATHROOM AMBUSH, WELL, IT
WASN'T APPROPRIATE BUT...
>> I DON'T THINK THEY ARE
APPROPRIATE TAXES BUT IT HAPPENS
TO EVERYBODY.
THE ONLY PEOPLE IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN TO OUR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SECRET SERVICE STANDING AROUND
THEM.
IT'S PART OF THE PROCESS.
>> Laura: FORGIVE MANCHIN AND
SINEMA.
ALL THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE
ANNOUNCING THIS TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR.
THEIR SILENCE SPEAKS VOLUMES
ABOUT HOW FAR LEFT THE PARTY HAS
GONE.
DEMOCRATS ARE READY TO THINK
THAT THE SPENDING DEBATE IS THE
LAST CHANCE.
IT'S THE LAST CHANCE TO SHOW
THAT THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
COMPLETELY TAKEN OVER BY THE
LOONIE LEFT.
IT'S THEIR LAST CHANCE TO SHOW
THAT THEY STILL BELIEVE IN OUR
BASIC ECONOMIC SYSTEM.
AND IT'S THEIR LAST CHANCE TO
ENCOURAGE THAT WE WILL RETURN TO
NORMAL.
IF THEY DON'T TAKE IT, IF THEY
KEEP PUSHING FOR TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT'S GOING TO SPUR